storyline number 12 for the 2019 sees
and focuses on a guy who looked to be on
track to be the 2017 NFL regular season
MVP and that's Carson Wentz the second
overall pick in 2016 who instantly
became a great player in the NFL and
could be the MVP in 2019 can Carson
Wentz stay healthy long enough to win
those awards we've seen him exit two
straight regular seasons in the month of
December we've seen Nick Foles come in
in relief of Carson Wentz 2017 he won
the Super Bowl in 2018 nearly got the
Eagles back to the NFC Championship game
now Falls is gone
all the more reason for Wentz to show
that he can stay healthy that he can be
effective even if he's a little more
careful with his body look it's a simple
matter of physics it's science it's
biology the more hits you take the more
likely you are to get injured and we've
seen Wentz take those hits he doesn't
shy away from it the problem is it puts
him on the sidelines and that doesn't
help his team will he stay healthy is
one of the biggest questions for 2019
and if he does the answer the question
ultimately maybe the Eagles back in the
Super Bowl and Wentz with both the
regular season MVP award and maybe just
maybe the Super Bowl MVP award as well
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports